Allah is with us in New York hi Ella
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you so much for taking my fault
today sure what's up I am in a terrible
situation I'm about a million dollars in
debt it's personal debt but on my
businesses but I saw a person off and I
can tell you that in credit cards I have
two hundred and sixty two thousand forty
seven thousand in a line of credit
business loans 134 thousand and I lost a
lawsuit that was due to coming issue and
one of my restaurants and that's at
three hundred thousand and then the
balance is sales tax mm-hmm how much do
in sales tax about four hundred thousand
okay are you losing money in the
restaurants so the restaurant like I
said they're two one is in the black for
about eight thousand dollars a month and
the others in the red at about five
thousand dollars a month and I've spent
so much so much of the money is going
back to pay the debt that I'm getting
into a situation where I can't pay rent
if they open I'm doing it but I can see
where it's headed
quickly really really quickly and the
attorney I have is telling me I need to
file bankruptcy and I'm talking to you
you may be bankrupt there's a couple
things you can try to avoid it and see
if you can turn the corner okay
any chance you could get a buyer on the
restaurant it's losing money I've been
trying to do that I've been trying to do
that when it's been closed and then it
falls through and then it
clothes and it's ok let's let's try to
keep that wrong that's thing number one
thing number two is you start paying
your sales tax immediately do not steal
that sales tax money anymore because
what's happening is you're using that to
do other operating things and pay this
debt and it's running that sales tax
bill up and in I always call it stealing
the sales tax because in a sense you're
it's money that was paid in sales tax by
the customer and then you didn't forward
it on to the government instead you used
it for cash flow problems ok
so if you'll start treating that in your
mind like it's stealing it'll help you
to remember to never do that anymore ok
so moving forward which I already plans
on doing figuring it out no matter what
the pace Elsa yeah yeah no matter what
from today forward you pay the sales tax
as it comes in every month ok it comes
in it goes right back out that's not
your money and and I'm afraid that 400k
and sales tax may not be deductible or
may not be bankrupt able I don't know in
your state what's the situation I'm
sorry it isn't from what I understand
yeah and so that's a reason to try to
stay alive rather than file bankruptcy
is to turn the corner on that 400 the
rest of these loans are not there at the
bottom of the list ok so the top of the
list is sales tax and operations staying
open paying your rent paying your
payroll staying open the only thing you
can use to pay on debt is money that is
left over after you stay open so you
don't use rent money to pay a stupid
credit card the credit card goes late
not the rent yeah you've got to
prioritize this and say what ernest esse
tees these unsecured creditors 134,000
and business loans line of credit credit
cards they're unsecured creditors
they're at the bottom of the list in a
bankruptcy and they're at the bottom of
the list right now you stay open to live
to fight another day and see if you
can't fight your way through it then
we'll go back and deal with those
unsecured Slater don't pay them another
dime right now